being the oldest remember the first
movie I saw in theatres was Return of
the Jedi and for me that moment when
Darth Vader's helmet comes off and you
see a fat sad though man underneath it
was incredibly traumatizing and also I'm
you know just never forget that moment
so yeah I grew up with my whole family
huge Star Wars fans
I was actually exposed to the
merchandise before the movie so I had
all the action figures toys bedspread
and then I watched the prequels and then
the originals after so that was my story
no I didn't how about what happens yeah
I actually did it that way as well I did
the prequels and then the girls because
of the I guess we just missed the
nineties babies in 92 yeah I mean I
think going out to the stage then it was
suddenly like yeah Wow
yeah because you can't imagine no yeah
you can't really picture what it is
until you see and also I think at least
for me I don't know if it was like this
for you guys but like getting cast into
being in it you kind of have to pretend
almost like it's not that big and it's
not a big deal is you know you're almost
the minute you diminish it a little bit
for yourself
but then you just can't fake it when you
get out there it becomes a religious
experience yeah yeah I also felt like we
were a bunch of friends on savages yeah
sure in a movie that we passionately
loved yeah and so the kind of massive
kind of Star Wars kind of energy wasn't
as exposed to our spot now it's real
it's real
it was more than noise for me because we
were waiting backstage and you could
just hear that like swell of the crowd
yeah and then watching it watching the
trailer with everyone yeah everyone was
breathing like one organism you know we
were all just on pins and needles it was
like I said it was almost like a
religious experience it brought me to
tears my heart was thumping but not out
of nervousness just out of just pure the
energy of yeah yeah yeah it's my first
time at any convention ever me today
yeah I've been to comic-con and done
Hawk oh hey I know how kind of crazy can
be but this is it's honestly especially
because it's all focus to one thing yeah
yeah yeah like it's all about style yeah
yeah it's just another energy
kind of going back to that idea that you
know you you forget about that while
you're shooting it as a necessity but
then to reconnect with that energy it is
exactly what it felt like when I was
little and you suddenly get exposed to
it and there's just something that's so
infectious about I think as as a group
like we've Star Wars fans there is
always a feeling of hope and are
something that we just saw there
everyone just had a feeling of you know
Star Wars is back and also we had that
feeling the whole way through filming
yeah there was never a day where we
didn't have that feeling so to have it
kind of reflected back on us to the
people that we're making us for is the
best the mark hamill think said it best
when he said family yeah huge family
because I think it is about family
ultimately the the stories are about
family you know like I said that moment
of eternal Jedi you know where suddenly
your father who's this godlike thing and
intimidating suddenly you realize that
he's just a vulnerable man yeah I think
the the biggest thing about these movies
is that it connects to the feeling of
family and about finding your place
within a world that like Luke starts out
he has no idea where he's gonna end up
and because of what he does he becomes
this kind of reverential man in the
universe and it feels like that
potentially yeah I think of any good
sci-fi oh the best sci-fi have a
fantastic human story wrapped around in
obviously force-sensitive sips and
Jedi's but it's something cool for
everyone to relate to
we feel exactly like everyone else does
because we I haven't seen anything else
I've just seen the trailer and I just
saw it like today yeah so we're as
excited as everyone else yes it's
impossible to continue filming every day
you have a new set that's actually there
of seaweeds in practical effects and
it's insane to be in the Star Wars
universe I mean this is the closest I'm
ever going to be to be a real trapped
space traveler it's kind of insane for
JJ Abrams who is incredible leader and
is able to infuse everyone no matter who
they are with excitement and he's just
incredibly kind and you know no matter
what was happening he would always find
time to speak with anyone to show to
share things with with all of us and
really to share most all his excitement
because for me this is the longest thing
I've ever done so it was I mean I was so
so nervous at the beginning but to feel
that kind of like family thing as well
as it might keep balances it so well so
it's like caring and you know he's
getting the best out of you and the
whole energy on set was just that's the
key there's that JJ brings out your best
yeah for me like I remember I've met JJ
in 2011 and I'm small moving could
attack the block I met him at his office
and he walked past me said to me we're
gonna get you in something we're gonna
get you in something a few years later
it was Star Wars and you know it you
know I had to work for it but it was
obviously something from goodwill and
belief in he has a belief in his actors
and who he really does have passion for
the art of filmmaking and passion for
souls
I mean the thing is in life which is sad
is it's usually a bad thing that unites
people so to be part of something
amazing that unites people all ages
genders race all languages they all come
together for this one thing it was
incredible it's got you know it's Star
Wars created a culture there's a whole
culture around it which is a such an
unusual thing and and I call to the
transcends where people are from just
like you said so that's that's pretty
pretty amazing to see those live feeds
come in those pictures from all across
the world and it's all universal
you